(dramatic electronic music)
- [Daniela] This lab in New York
and others around the world
are racing to answer one of
the most important questions
that we have right now.
How well will our current
vaccines protect us
from Omicron, that new
worrisome COVID variant?
- As we expected, Omicron
is quite resistant.
So it evades detection and inhibition
by the antibodies we produce,
either after vaccination
or prior infection.
- [Daniela] However, there's
also good news, a booster.
- Maintains the level of
activity against Omicron.
There should be sufficient
to provide protection.
- [Daniela] The lab at
Rockefeller University is one
of the leaders doing these
types of experiments.
So I went to get an exclusive look
at the kinds of tests
virologist need to do,
to come up with those conclusions,
and what the results might
mean for us going forward.
When I visited virologists,
Theodora Hatziioannou and Paul Bieniasz,
were about to finish some key experiments.
Since around Thanksgiving,
their lab has been working
around the clock on Omicron.
They've been testing
antibodies and samples
from three groups.
People who have recovered from COVID,
some of whom got vaccinated.
People who have gotten
boosters of Pfizer's vaccine
and people who just got a
single dose of the J&J shot.
The testing involves looking
at a key part of the virus,
plus patient samples like this one,
and then how the antibodies
in those samples interact
with the virus.
- We're basically mimicking
what happens in your body
when the virus enters your body
and encounters your antibodies.
- [Daniela] During My visit,
Theodora showed me a kind of heat map
of antibody virus interactions.
- If it's capable of
inhibiting virus infection,
you will turn the red into
a light orange, green,
and even blue, if the
plasma is quite powerful,
so you get...
- [Daniela] Like an alert,
the more red you see,
the less effective antibodies
are at attacking the virus,
and the more of it that
can get into cells.
That's what happened
when they tested Omicron.
The day after my visit,
they had the results.
- [Paul] some neutralization, but...
- [Daniela] Neutralization
or the ability of antibodies
to keep Omicron from entering cells
was generally lower in Paul
and Theodora's experiments.
The data corroborates with corporate
and academic labs have found so far.
That current vaccines may be
less effective against Omicron
than previous versions of the virus.
Theodora's and other researchers
data point to a future
where boosters are the norm
and vaccines get tailored
to specific variants.
- It really means you
should get a boosters
as soon as possible,
and boosters should be extended
to all age categories, including kids.
- [Daniela] So how do the test
that help guide our vaccine
strategy actually work?
Researchers start by
building a lab-grown version
of Omicron spike protein from scratch.
The spike protein is what
helps the virus get into cells.
It's also a key target for
virus-busting antibodies.
Fabian Schmidt is the researcher
in charge of reconstructing
the spike protein.
He gave me a tour of the building process,
starting with an online database
of viral genetic sequences.
- So you can see South African,
and then this is now even
allocated up, Omicron.
- [Daniela] That genetic
information serves as the blueprint
for Omicron spike.
The researchers use bacterial cells
to copy that genetic code.
Each one of the dots you
see here represents a clone
or specimen of spike protein DNA.
The other piece of the puzzle is the shell
of a completely different virus
to which they attach the
lab-grown Omicron spike protein.
These are basically neutered viruses.
They can get into cells,
but they lack the machinery
to reproduce and spread.
That's key because it's
what allows the researchers
to measure the extent
to which antibodies can
stop the spike protein
from getting these fake
viruses to latch onto
and infect cells.
In a separate and secured
section of the lab,
The researchers incubate their fake virus
with patient samples
from vaccinated people
and people who've had COVID.
That liquid has antibodies.
The virus antibody mixture is an added
to cells that have been
sitting in a warm incubator
inside these little black containers.
Critically, these cells have the receptor
that the spike protein binds to,
allowing the virus to enter.
If the neutered virus gets in,
it varies a set of instructions
that tells the cells
to make luciferase.
That's a protein that glows
and is measured
by the instrument Theodora
showed us earlier.
More glow means more infection,
which is shown in red.
That means the antibodies
that were less effective.
They compared how well antibodies
prevented Omicron spike
from helping the virus get into cells,
relative to the original version of spike.
And they found that-
- The antibodies in our body,
particularly over time,
appear a really poor at
dealing with Omicron.
- [Daniela] The samples they tested
from patients span several months,
from right after they were
vaccinated or infected,
to months later.
And we know that antibody
levels tend to wane with time.
Plus none of these people
were infected with Omicron.
When people got boosters, though,
their antibody levels went up and-
- Do retain sufficient
activity to make us hopeful
that these people will be able to deal
with Omicron infections.
- [Daniela] Theodora said
that the extra antibodies
that boosters provide
should help protect us
against the most severe outcomes,
including hospitalization.
- I still remain worried
that Omicron will transmit
between vaccinated people easier.
So we still need to have
masks and social distancing
for a little while longer.
- [Daniela] In the coming weeks,
we should have more definitive answers
about Omicron's real world impact
from data on how well vaccines protect
people, not just cells.
Public health experts will be able to see
whether vaccinated people
are getting more breakthrough infections.
Those have tended to be milder, but-
- What is really driving
evolution and emergence
of the variants is resistant
to our antibody responses.
- [Daniela] Theodora and others said
that vaccination rates need to increase
to give the virus fewer chances to infect,
mutate and pose new threats in the future.
(upbeat electronic music)